hello everyone and welcome to math
simplified
i'm dr umar malik and i'm back with
another interesting video
today we'll be taking a look at few
signs and symptoms
that you can develop if you have a liver
disease
your liver does a lot of things to keep
you healthy
it is especially important as it acts as
your body's
filter to clear out toxins this includes
clearing the blood of drugs and other
poisonous substances such as
ammonia liver produces bile
which helps to carry away waste products
and breaks down
fats in the gut during digestion it also
produces certain proteins for blood
plasma
and other important molecules such as
cholesterol which are especially
important for transport of vital
nutrients throughout the body
the proteins that are produced by the
liver play numerous important roles in
our body
additionally but equally important is
its role in maintaining our body's
energy level in the form of glucose
it converts excess glucose into glycogen
for storage
this glycogen can later be converted
back to glucose for energy
this is important for our body's
survival and helps us feed hunger
and stay active for extended periods of
time
you may not know it but the liver has an
important role in resisting infections
also
this is because the liver makes numerous
immune factors to fight off
microorganisms
and also removes bacteria from the
bloodstream keeping us healthy
some factors like heavy consumption of
alcohol
chronic viral infections and eating an
unhealthy diet for too long
or overdose of commonly prescribed
medications can cause liver damage
other factors that may increase your
chances of getting liver disease
include obesity type 2 diabetes
tattoos or body piercings drug abuse
exposure to other people's blood and
body fluids
unprotected sex exposure to certain
chemicals or toxins
and a family history of liver disease
when some of these risk factors are
present
your liver may get stressed out this
will lead to liver injury which can
present in various peculiar
yet vague signs and symptoms according
to experts
very few people actually know when liver
is failing
this is because most of the people
aren't aware of what causes liver
failure
and even lesser people know how to look
out for the symptoms
so let's take a look at some of the
common signs and symptoms
of liver injury or liver failure if you
see one
or more of these signs you should
immediately consult a medical
professional to rule out any underlying
disease
number one loss of appetite a
disinterest in food
loss of appetite and weight loss are
some of the early symptoms of liver
problems
number two fluid retention fluid
retention
is also one of the most common signs of
liver disease
it appears in more than 50 of people who
have cirrhosis
a condition in which scar tissue
replaces healthy liver tissue
accumulating fluid may cause distension
of your abdomen
also known as ascitus or may lead to
swelling in your legs
known as edema this happens because due
to long-term liver disease
high blood pressure develops in your
liver veins this also happens when your
liver is unable to make albumin
a protein that prevents the leakage of
fluid from your bloodstream
into the adjoining tissues both of these
factors
lead to eventual fluid leakage from your
blood vessels
and fluid accumulation into your abdomen
or under your skin
treatment options for fluid retention
include a low sodium diet
which helps to treat mild fluid
retention for moderate to severe fluid
retention your doctor may prescribe
certain medications known as diuretics
which help in removing the excess fluid
from your body
by increasing your urine output but in
some severe cases
your doctor can advise a procedure known
as parasynthesis
using a needle doctor perform
parasynthesis to drain the excess
abdominal fluid
which leads to temporary but instant
relief
number three jaundice jaundice is a
condition that causes darker urine and a
yellowish tint in your skin
it can also lead to yellowing of whites
of your eyes
also known as sclera it appears when
bilirubin builds up in your bloodstream
bilirubin is a pigment that forms when
red blood cells are broken down
usually a healthy liver absorbs
bilirubin and converts it into bile
this bile is then excreted by your body
with your stools
but a diseased liver is unable to do so
hence yellowish bilirubin accumulates in
your body
and causes yellowish discoloration of
skin eyes and urine
you may ask what are the treatment
options of jaundice
well that basically depends upon the
reason why jaundice has developed in the
first place
and there can be a wide variety of
reasons your doctor will evaluate you
by performing different types of tests
like a complete blood count
liver function tests ultrasonography of
your liver
and liver biopsy if needed
number four increased tendency of
bleeding
a healthy liver produces clotting
factors which are basically proteins
that are activated whenever you are
injured these proteins lead to formation
of a blood clot
which stops the bleeding an unhealthy
liver leads to a decreased
production of these clotting factors
which ultimately results in an
increased tendency to bleed so whenever
you are injured it takes a longer time
for your body to stop the bleeding
you may also experience bruises under
your skin with minor trauma
patients with advanced liver disease
such as liver failure
have very low levels of these clotting
factors and can experience
episodes of spontaneous bleeding without
any injury
these patients may bleed into their
stomach which results
in blood in their vomit or they can even
experience
bleeding in their lungs which can result
in blood during coughing
liver cirrhosis leads to an enlarged
spleen known as splenomegaly
our spleen has a job of collecting
platelets from our blood
and their storage when spleen gets
enlarged excessive amounts of platelets
are removed by the spleen from a blood
this phenomena is known as splenic
sequestration
this may lead to a very low platelet
count which makes you more susceptible
to nose bleeds and bleeding gums
number five confusion your liver is the
major purifier of toxins from your blood
and it also metabolizes a lot of
chemicals we ingest
such as those present in our food and
medicines
when your liver is unable to filter
these toxins
these may travel and accumulate in your
brain the resulting condition
known as hepatic encephalopathy can
cause confusion
memory problems lethargy and in later
stages
even coma number six
frequent nausea and vomiting this also
results
due to liver's inability to remove
toxins from our blood
which slowly build up and trigger
certain areas in our brain
that results in nausea and vomiting in
our upcoming videos about liver health
we'll talk about what are the common
reasons of liver disease
and we will also make a video on how to
keep your liver healthy
so make sure to subscribe to our channel
so you don't miss out on those videos
well friends we at mess simplified
believe that you should never ignore
symptoms
always consult a medical professional if
you see any of these above symptoms
with this we come to an end of this
short video do remember to share this
video and press the like button
if you like what we do consider joining
us on our youtube channel by becoming a
member
and you can also support us via patreon
links are in the description below
thank you and take care see you in the
next video